- HI, HONEY.
- JUST GETTING RID
OF MY TOYS, MOM.
I'M READY FOR
THE REAL THING.
[train engine chugging]
[pop music]
♪ WHOA, WHOA, GIRL
♪ COULD YOU BE THE FIRST
TO TAKE ME ALL THE WAY? ♪
♪ I AIN'T A LITTLE BOY
NO MORE ♪
♪ I'M THROWIN' MY TOYS AWAY
♪ TRADE MY SCOOTER
FOR A SKATEBOARD ♪
♪ LEAVE THE CRUST
ON MY BREAD ♪
♪ I'M DONE WITH
TAKING BATHS ♪
♪ I'M TAKING SHOWERS INSTEAD
♪ GOT MY BRACES OFF
♪ I'M ALMOST READY
TO SHAVE ♪
♪ I'M NOT AFRAID
OF COOTIES ♪
♪ I'M ALL MANLY AND BRAVE
♪ SO SEND IN A SELFIE
♪ AND IN TEN WORDS
OR LESS ♪
♪ TELL US WHY YOU
GOT TO BE THE ONE ♪
♪ TO WIN THIS CONTEST
♪ THE FIRST TIME IS SACRED
♪ WANNA SHARE IT WITH YOU
♪ TO GET WITH ME NAKED
♪ GIRL, ONE THING
YOU GOT TO DO ♪
- ♪ WHOA
♪ YOU GOT
TO ENTER TO WIN ♪
♪ A CHANCE TO BE WITH ME
♪ SO I CAN ENTER YOU
AND LOSE MY VIRGINITY ♪
♪ YOU MUST BE 18 TO WIN
♪ NO PURCHASE NECESSARY
♪ AND I'M LIKE
WHOA, WHOA, YEAH ♪
♪ YEAH, COME ON, BABY
♪ ENTER TO WIN
- IT'S THE ENTER TO WIN
SWEEPSTAKES.
ONE GRAND PRIZE WINNER
AND THREE FRIENDS
WILL BE FLOWN TO ONTARIO,
WHERE THEY'LL GET
TO MEET BRYAN IN A HOTEL
AND TAKE HIS VIRGINITY.
GET YOUR PARENTS' OKAY
TO TAKE A SELFIE
AND SEND IT IN
A STAMPED ENVELOPE
TO THE BRYAN LA CROIX
FAN CLUB.
- ♪ GOT TO ENTER TO WIN
♪ A CHANCE TO BE WITH ME
♪ SO I CAN ENTER YOU
AND LOSE MY VIRGINITY ♪
♪ COME ON, GIRL,
DON'T BE SHY ♪
I'M SO EXCITED FOR WHOEVER
WINS THE CONTEST.
IT'S GONNA BE
A REALLY TENDER NIGHT.
- AND WATCH "WHEELS ONTARIO"
WEEKENDS AT 9:00.